hi mr. Shapiro I'm curious what would a
University's proper response in dealing
with nonviolent hate speech be into the
law I mean we have to define hate speech
so one of the big problems with hate
speech is that it has a completely fluid
definition sometimes it just means me
saying biological sex exists and
sometimes it means Nazis marching around
on campus in rare occasion so let's so
what are we talking about
so someone drawing something like
something racist on a wall someone deems
it like really offensive or maybe
violent but it's not directed toward
anyone specifically well I mean I think
that universities do have a right to
determine whether a person is fit to be
on their campus but I'm very leery I'm
very leery of saying that racist speech
for example is the reason to kick
somebody off campus I think that I think
is a very it's it's a dangerous problem
it really runs afoul of First Amendment
principles to me and again I think
people who do that are disgusting and
horrible and I think that that's a bad
social strategy if you want to have
friends or have a decent life but I
think that if the university starts
determining what speech it likes and
what speech it doesn't and then it
starts banning people based on which
speech you legs on which speech it
doesn't that's a that's a pretty
dangerous power and it is it it is a
content-based power okay they answered
my question thank you
[Applause]